[Music]
it's film bachelorette and I'm curious
have you been to a bachelorette party
have you experienced one I threw my
mother a bachelorette party right before
she got married and I took it to a strip
club this is not a great idea and I for
some reason dressed her in a red leather
dog's collar also not a good idea oh
this is let's back this thing way up
this is we it's all happening too fast
for me these you've just listing things
that would never happen with my mom you
took her to a male strip club artist
correct and I had never been to one
before and I didn't know they took up
all their clothes
I thought they stayed in shorts and it
was very I know no no wait a minute wait
am I don't take off all their clothes oh
well they did the one I worked at we
[Applause]
kept a small little thing with a
shamrock on it
that never came up this is one so you
took her there she had a dog school I
know because it was supposed to be fun
and it was just the most and I was quite
I thought it would be quite you know a
great story to tell later yeah but then
I went to the is that and so then I
guess you got pulled up on stage and
everyone was still enjoying it and [ __ ]
you know we were making eye contact and
everything was great and then I went to
the bathroom just just very briefly and
when I came back the gentleman had
pulled off everything and was basically
about to teabag mime okay
[Applause]
wait you feel differently than you sure
this was a strip club in Weston in
Western Australia in Perth Australia you
people crazy my poor mama Joe he is his
stop out if you don't think out and
literally hovering over her and her
friends just it was just it all just
went wrong did she recover from this did
she say like let's go back tomorrow I
mean what happened yeah she's so
good-natured she just loved through it
she she coped pretty well did you last
really so that's crazy